it is time for drew's news your daily
good news huddle
and with me
and with me at the desk is co-captain of
the drew's news team rossi ross matthews
[Applause]
thank you let's dive in with a juicy
question today here it is
should your co-workers feel like your
family the advice column at the cut
recently tackled this topic they got a
letter from someone who works at a
nonprofit where social functions and a
family vibe are a big part of the
company culture this person said they
don't always want to participate because
their work-life balance gets off but
they're worried they'll miss a promotion
or an opportunity just because they
didn't go on like drinks and scavenger
hunts all that stuff ross thoughts well
i think it depends on the job i mean
here you and i are like baked into one
little hot pocket we are close
and because we are ourselves here we
share but i remember when i worked at
mcdonald's and yes i was a triple threat
i did the drive through the register and
the grill that means i was like the
beyonce of mcdonald's
i was i was not like i i have to admit i
wasn't all up in what my co-workers were
doing because i don't know i just didn't
have that connection i think it's a
really interesting topic and the reason
i gravitated towards this article is
because i push family culture
and i think that we spend so much time
at work so if there's a way to be a
human at work and relate to people and
make it personal i just think it's a
better use of time i think so too next
if you like to sleep naked as the day
you were born apparently the writers at
newsweek want you to go for it they
talked to a bunch of sleep scientists
and psychologists and collected every
single reason that you should
leave stark naked here are just a few
sleeping nude helps you fall asleep
faster
a cooler sleep temperature leads to a
deeper non-rem
sleep for more restorative sleep
and it can even help with male fertility
oh and vaginal health oh my goodness
what all of a sudden we went goop on
them
i know
hey guess what
did you hear the news
[Laughter]
newsweek is real hot to trot on this
subject ross thoughts i have so many
thoughts right now
[Laughter]
i'll i'll tell you i don't sleep in the
nude um it's not for me um
no
i
i have it do you sleep in
pajamas not silk pajamas no i pictured
you on celery no don't picture me at all
i just you know it's not i like to be
covered head to toe but what do you
sleep in
um well again it depends on the
situation um if uh there's no one around
i am a total nudie
i love sleeping naked i like walking to
my kitchen naked i love just walking
around the house naked yes i
[Applause]
that's right
um okay by show of polls
i wanna are we really asking about
nudity and poles in the same size
absolutely okay who's a fan of sleeping
oh net tua as they say a lot of green a
lot of green a lot of green some red
okay uh we have a fatima in the audience
fatima why do you like sleeping naked
literally every benefit you listed i
sleep so much better i'm more well
rested and i'm just i toss and turn too
much at night and pajamas are way too
restricting
[Music]